okay so what's your question oh so like
for me um I was with a woman for 10
years yeah and she was a stay-at-home
mom for three qus of that yeah but the
mortgage was in her name MH so now I'm
having to sue her to get my ass My
Equity out of the house how was the how
did they approve a mortgage in her name
if she wasn't working she had a job when
we got together oh she quit she quit
when she was pregnant with her second
child okay and then you just took care
of paying the mortgage they didn't ask
for any updated proof of income or
anything like that no mortgage is always
paid yeah
um well that's a legal question so
whatever the Line in the Sand is that
the family lawyer says in your state is
kind of like you know the rule of law
but if it's if it states that you know
it's this then go for this and make sure
you're firm on it you there's a whole
bunch of stuff that you can do to sort
of encourage her in that direction where
are you at in the process you still in
the house you move out of the house you
oh no I've been out I've been out for
over a year and a half but in uh
litigation for about 14
months yeah um and what's her position
on the matrimonial
asset well we weren't married so uh
that's why law NOP we don't we don't
have common law so you don't have common
law so so what's the problem she doesn't
want to give you half the house oh no
she thinks she told me to consider it
rent
[Laughter]
yeah my friend you're gonna have to
lawyer up on that one you're going to be
up for an upill battle oh I'm six grand
in already yeah it's probably hting that
bad yeah the bills the Bill's probably
gonna keep keep getting racked up but uh
joint custody cost me 20 yeah it is what
it is that's what that's what happens
when you invite the state into your life
you know this is why I keep telling guys
you know if you get married in the west
you invite the state into your house and
stuff in family law does not encourage
women to behave well so the notion of
unjust enrichment that you're describing
there is what many guys go through I
don't know what the percentage is but
many guys go through it where it's like
she just looks at the laws or she sits
down with her girlfriends one night gets
smashed over a bottle of wine and
they're like hey girl you know you can
do this that and the other thing and
she's like yeah [__] that guy I'm gonna
then you know you're in for the battle
it's that's just the way that family law
is guys so I mean I I can't really do
anything for you Bobby there's no
machine I can put you in uh send you
back to a time where you don't get you
know live with this woman and put babies
in her you somebody better obviously but
um maybe let maybe the lesson here so
let's so let's go about it this route to
give the viewers a little bit of a
lesson so have you read my book have you
got gotten into the red flag chapter I
have I have bought your book I have not
gotten to read it yet okay I just got it
recently okay so there's probably red
flags there so maybe you go through that
then you can come back on and say hey
look you know she had these three six 17
red flags so had I paid attention to
this then I could have potentially
avoided this uh slight train wreck that
I'm in right now but it sounds like
you're GNA have to lawyer up and rely on
the lawyer's advice and do what you got
to do to get this thing fixed yeah I
guess uh I was actually calling in more
almost as information for a guy who does
get with somebody and they're together
long enough she could
have potentially equity in a state
yeah there's um there's that with the
cohabitation agreement yeah there's that
famous story about that footballer um it
was it was back in the summertime and he
and he got with
a Spanish I don't know newscaster or
soap opera actress or some [__] like
that and this footballer put all of his
assets all of his paychecks went to his
mom he had nothing in his name nothing
in her name and it all went to his mom
and I think the the end result of it or
where they were getting to was that she
was going to have to pay him money
because he technically was worth nothing
um so he structured himself in such a
way that he couldn't get [__] over so
that's that's some precautionary steps
to the like that's some God mode stuff
right there um yeah I'm not saying that
you necessarily you know should have to
do that but that's that's a pretty good
insurance policy especially again when
women reserve the right to change their
mind at any given
time yeah I'm not so sure that the stay
at home mom thing didn't help yeah it it
doesn't so to sort of explain to the
audience
like it's kind of [__] you know because
we keep telling guys you know the best
thing is that she does the pink jobs
does the mommy stuff and raises the kids
especially for the first few years when
they're small when they need that sort
of stuff and the guy you know Dad can do
like you know the manly stuff when they
come closer to of age you know S 8 10
you know stuff like that um so the state
at home Mommy notion seems like a good
idea but the problem with that is Bobby
gets to go ahead and pursue his career
and make his money and he you know he
goes out and brings brings home the
bacon and the social contract that you
have is that she cooks it up right um as
a consequence of that though she
abandons her ability to make money she
quits her job and she stays home to
raise the kids then her argument becomes
when you're un tying the knot well I
gave up my career so Bobby could pursue
his so now I like my skills are out of
date I can't work I need his income
right because when you're married she's
all strong and independent I don't need
no man you can't tell me what to do but
all of a sudden now when you're getting
divorced oh I can't cope I can't make
you know ends meet on my own he has to
pay for everything blah blah blah blah
blah right so that's the problem with
the stay-at-home mom uh issue
which become res yeah and if you're in a
state where it's default 5050 you don't
even have to have that fight
right like that's one of the pre
preventative measures that you can put
in place to sort of protect you from
that but nobody thinks about these
things you know beforehand you didn't I
didn't you know I thought you know you
just get married and everything's fine
if it doesn't work out you just untie
the knot and everything's fine but no
that's not how it works out I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out